so today we're talking about teaching at
Yale and I want to focus on teaching
graduate students at Yale and in
particular I want to focus on a part of
graduate education at the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences and that is
teaching graduate students how to teach
and so I want to start from the back end
which is the end goal of the PhD which
from what i hear is a job and i did an
extremely scientific google search of
The Chronicle of Higher Education and
inside higher ed and can anyone guess
what percentage of job postings within
the Academy now ask for some degree of
online education experience this is the
interactive portion 50 75 100 okay
that's that's optimistic anyone else no
one's guessing lower 10 okay so weighted
average of all of them is forty-nine
percent if you look at academic jobs
wiki which tends to focus on junior
faculty positions those the number raise
it right goes up to sixty percent which
is essentially to say that one out of
every two jobs that you're bright
graduate students who are either your
your students or your TFS are going to
one day be applying for our asking us to
have some experience with online
education and that means that I think we
need to think very seriously about how
to include graduate students and
training graduate students in this
online education revolution so two
things that we're currently doing last
year for the first time the Yale
teaching center ran our first workshop
on preparing to teach an online class
which was a particular challenge because
the other facilitator and I had both
never taught an online class but we did
a lot of research and we had some really
great discussions and we're currently
exploring opportunities with Lucas about
allowing and mentoring students through
preparing a five minute demo reel a
number of jobs are now asking students
for evidence of facility and online
teaching and so allowing graduate
students to make a demo reel as part of
their job application package maybe
they're teaching portfolio is one thing
that we're looking at doing in terms of
in terms of giving us some of that
experience
so I'm going to be very short and I just
want to raise one sort of systemic
question and then I want to leave us
with one large take away and the
systemic question is one that I think
has been raised already about how many
faculty we're going to need if we are
sharing brilliant online classes and the
most the most clear example of this is
the is the network that we have about
sort of very rare languages that we
currently have with a number of other
universities now if the entire northeast
needs one professor of Polish and I
picked it randomly I'm not nothing
against polish then we need to think
about our responsibility in terms of PhD
admissions about how many PhDs in Polish
we're training who may or may not get
jobs and so one thing to think about as
we do this is how does admissions
reflect this online revolution but my
most important piece of advocacy might
my takeaway is it's important given the
market and given where education is
going that we give graduate students the
opportunity to experience online
education most of us are slightly older
than the curve so most of us did not
take online classes but we will be
expected to give them and through summer
summer classes TF assignments other
opportunities that we can be creative in
allowing graduate students to have this
experience I think we're going to be
much more compelling candidates on the
market I think there may be a tendency
there's a lot to learn when you're
learning to give an online course and I
think there may be a tendency to find a
TF who knows how to do it and then just
stick with them for the next four
semesters I'm sure that would be easier
to for everyone involved but I think
it's going to be very important to think
about how we include a broad number of
graduate students across fields in this
the statistic that I started with is
consistent whether you're talking about
medieval studies or actually computer
science had a slightly lower percentage
but whether regardless of where you're
talking whatever field you think is the
field where everybody's doing online
education it's really across the board
and so I think we need to find ways to
include graduate students throughout
that process thank you
you